so the topic of this session is data
analysis with sy DB pie and will be done
by Chris Beaumont and Alex yeah so alex
is with side eb and graces with with a
Howard Center for Astrophysics yes and
some of you might know him from the
Howard cs101 notebooks if you haven't
seen them you should look them up online
they're really good resource we will
hand it over to Chris okay so we're
gonna be talking about data analysis
with steady beep I alex is going to
start talking about citing be generally
I'll come in about maybe I have third or
half way through and talk about the
Python interface to that so I'll hand it
over to Alex all right hello Lou thanks
for coming everybody it's been a long
day and we'll try to be entertaining
that's Chris and I'm Alex we're talking
about psyd b-side eb is a MPP database
that is unique in that it is a
distributed database for storing and
representing array data the database
deals with sparse indents
multi-dimensional arrays and allows you
to complex analytics on array data
inside the database the database runs on
commodity clusters or in the cloud and
you can interface with the database
directly via r and python so chris is
going to talk about specifically the
python integration story before we get
into that i'll give you a general
overview of what's ITB is as seen from
any language perspective this slide we
affectionately refer to as the three
pillars of eid be it was developed by
Mike Stonebreaker how many of you have
heard the name before stonebraker there
you go so here's mo is that he's a
professor at MIT and every five years or
so he comes up with a new kind of
database technology he was one of the
first guys behind postgres then followed
by Illustra stream-based vertica volt DB
and now sigh DB and after sigh DB is
also now he's working on something
called data tamer which is a new thing
if you want to have a fun conversation
ask Stonebraker what he thinks about
Hadoop so sigh TB is released as we have
a free and open community edition you
can download it today and play around
with it and get some functionality out
of it it will scale to as many notes as
you want we have these cards here at the
front that have instructions for how you
can download the system and the Free
Edition is also highly extensible and
then on top of that paradigm for
incorporated cells take the proprietary
closed source plugins that plug into the
open source core and extend the system
with enterprise level features make the
math run faster and of course we sell
you support licenses as well our first
customer started out at NCBI NIH it's
called the thousand genomes project it's
not growing to a lot more than a
thousand and they are cataloging
information on how people as genomes
differ from one individual to another
and being able to trace ancestry genetic
differences susceptibility to diseases
and so on and it turns out that that
kind of information is very good for an
array database they've been running
twenty-four seven since fall 2012 if you
go to that URL you will see a nice tool
and that tool draws its data directly
from site eb the thousand genomes rosa
we're getting other interaction in
different markets so personalized
medicine genomics is a big one there's a
lot of cancer companies around the
cambridge area that want to find drugs
that target cancer other types of
genomics plant genomics ecommerce
recommendation engines finance
correlations and classifications and
machine learning image and sensor and
industrial analytics and also since as
the name lens as the name says it's ITB
scientific database was originally
intended for hot big science use cases
so we have a lot of use cases in
National Labs NASA Lawrence Berkeley and
so forth so they a lot of those folks
use the Community Edition and a lot of
them are work
with us and doing interesting things
this is the key idea behind psyd be so
we believe strongly that data should be
represented and organized and stored as
multi-dimensional arrays and that's so
this is this is our corp thesis if you
will this data is stock trades right I
think everybody in the room would be
familiar with that in Europe you can
imagine a space that's created by two
axes time and stock symbol and cells in
this space organized in a sparse array
where in each cell has in and of itself
a structure of typed attributes so in
each cell here we have a price and the
volume price might be a double a double
precision value and the volume might be
a UN 64 and this structure is sparse
because trades don't occur every nano
seconds the they occurred every
granularity they occur with some
intervals and and so this this is the
kind of data model that site eb allows
you to build site eb allows you to
organize your data in this way so you
load your data in and you say time and
stock are my dimensions and price and
volume are my attributes and you can
create an array like this this is in
contrast to something like our for
example or python where you can either
have a multi-dimensional array of of a
single attribute our does that very
pretty well on a single machine or you
can have a data frame in our that has
many attributes but then it's no longer
multi-dimensional so one of the
differentiators of sight baby is being
able to have multi multiple dimensions
multiple attributes in a database and so
okay i've organized my data in this way
and it's stored this way that's so great
what do i do with it and the simple
thing you could do is just slicing and
dicing give me the value of microsoft
and something else between this time and
that time and pull it out into some
other process and analyze it that's
pretty trivial dimensional lookups you
could do aggregations inside the
database deuce sums counts give me the
pipe
hi-lo open closed for the day for every
stock again very very pretty simple
stuff and now let's do something more
interesting let's take this matrix take
the time axis and compress it from nano
seconds to say seconds now imagine the
matrix getting squished down like this
imagine each new cell of the new matrix
containing an average of all the trades
that occurred in that second so now
we're talking about a dense matrix
that's shorter this way but it's still
stalk by time now we essentially
multiply this matrix by its transpose
and apply some centering to every cell
and what we can get out of that is a
correlation matrix so the output would
be a first the covariance and then it's
easy to turn the covariance matrix into
a correlation matrix which would be
stock versus stock and for each pair
stocks we would get a position I would
get a correlation value of how closely
those two stocks how closely the two
stocks correlate each other one goes up
what does the other do right and then
you can plot a graph of the most highly
correlated stocks this was generated
with sy t bu ting are for example and
you can see here's all the banks of
america Bank of America JPMorgan Wells
Fargo goldman sachs there's
pharmaceutical stocks up there there's
all the tech stocks Amazon Apple
Microsoft IBM so now i have now if i
have a picture like this i can actually
make money right i can i can bet on one
when one goes up and expect the other
one to go up as well right so this is
this is the kind of thing thats ITB was
built for right being able to store the
data and being able to analyze it like
this right all the Japanese companies
end up in one corner there interestingly
enough and interestingly enough Walmart
is very closely related to SAP like who
knew right and of course as soon as you
do this for somebody what are they going
to tell you they're going to say that
right well you did 5,000 America
stocks now do all the stocks in the
world you know you did it going back one
week now do it going back five years
write the data volumes just keep growing
and we're building a system to
accommodate for that right and this
doesn't just apply to stock trades right
so if you have any kind of imagery and
you want to do image analysis with if
you have those like brain scans
geographical imagery satellite imagery
astronomy will show you this is a
genomics example where you have samples
of tissue that were collected may be
from different cancer patients and for
each sample we have all the genes that
we've cataloged in the human genome and
for a particular sample in a particular
gene we have a value for how much the
gene is expressed and how many copy
number variations there are in the gene
that tells us if the gene has been up
regulated through an unnatural mutation
which sometimes happens during cancer
and how much how much protein expression
there is so when the gene gets
translated into protein how much how
much of that do we find in a cell
because very often that kind of up
regulation is what would cause a cancer
and it turns out that the genomics guys
and the cancer treatment guys very often
do the exact same kind of correlation
they want to do a gene versus gian
correlation from a set of samples they
can see which genes are related to each
other so we see patterns across
industries that make a good use case for
a system like ours and you know you
could imagine having a third dimension
here cancer type going out of the matrix
right we're not we're not going out of
the out of the screen so we're not
limited to two dimensions and truly n
dimensional arrays right so you can
start to get a feel for the kind of use
cases were built for a little bit about
how the system is architected and how
the system is built so here we have our
cloud which site EB is running inside of
it can be done in in indoor in the
enterprise on on commodity hardware or
it can be done in inside
an environment like ec2 and we
distribute the data among n machines so
the more machines the merrier each
machine gets a portion of the data and
then you can interact interact with the
system we have our own query language we
try to make it look close to sequel but
if you don't like that you can also
interact with the system using our and
this package called side EBR or using
Python and a package called sigh DB pie
so Chris is taking no no or taking over
ownership of sight EVP and that's what
he's going to be talking about and
there's a JDBC connector and other good
stuff so your array data imagine your
two-dimensional array and this is
showing up horribly they're supposed to
be little cells here but so your array
space would be split in rectilinear
chunks right imagine if it's sparse or
dense your array is split into little
squares and those squares are
distributed between different machines
like that so pieces of the array are
sent to different machines in the
cluster and then when if you if you need
to optionally you can also specify an
overlap for example for stock trades if
you're fine you're doing one minute
moving averages very often you can tell
the system to store of for each of the
array chunks one minute before and after
each window of data so that when you do
when you want to do a windowed aggregate
for an average price you don't have to
do enter instance communication so
that's called that's called that's
called overlap and that's another
feature that that that we have that's
very good form for multi-dimensional
windowed aggregates I really wish you'd
see my grey cells I'm kind of bummed out
but try think this is a better image the
other point I want to make here is that
data is clustered so data that are close
together an n-dimensional space are also
stored close together on disk so you
define the dimensions and if the data
are close in the n-dimensional space
they'll also be stored close together a
single chunk so very often when you have
a query that says give me everything
around a particular region or give me
everything
for a particular stock then we have a
very clever index that's actually based
on the hashing of the coordinates of the
values and we can just pick only one
chunk to look at or only a set of chalk
to look only a set of chunks to look at
we can do that very quickly so those
kinds of slice and dice queries run very
quickly thanks to our chunking right so
what we get is we get a benefit for for
quick lookups by dimension so give me
everything for Microsoft for this date
would happen very quickly because the
system knows exactly what chunk to go to
even without consulting any kind of
index just by the coordinates no and
also this kind of layout of data is
pretty good for massive linear algebra
so how many people I've heard of scale
it back or lay back okay so scale it
back is a is a is a way to do scalable
linear algebra that's pretty much 30
years old and hasn't been beaten it so
it's it's a very fast way to multiply
matrices on a grid of computers and we
put that inside the engine right so
inside the engine the user says multiply
two matrices side EB fires up scale up
back and scale-up back does all the hard
work the data gets rotated between the
instances and so forth yes sir sorry if
the two arrays are out of memory there's
some there's some other algorithms we've
built around that so scale of back
worked in memory only you can tune scale
a pact to give it some swap which you
know might might complicate things and
then we have our own we have some other
algorithms that we've built for matrix
multiplication and for SVD that would do
out of memory but of course if you're
doing matrix multiplication that's order
n cube and you're hitting the disk every
time that might not finish in a while so
if you wanted to take a week you know it
depends on your objectives right and so
the idea is you don't need to have to
load data into a separate math package
anymore and in addition to linear
algebra we support principal component
analysis we have a good generalized
linear model function and we're
expanding the library of things we
support right and in addition to all
that it's a database right so we have
acid guarantees you can have multiple
users hitting the data at the same time
you can join a raise based on their
dimensions or their attributes soon the
the security and the access control
stuff is coming soon there's data
replication in the enterprise version
for good failure recovery so for now it
goes down the system stays operational
and there's also a feature called the
ray versioning so that every time you
change data in an array that creates a
new version and you can go back to an
old version and see what the state of
the world was in the past before you've
made changes important to point out what
it's not right it's not a good document
store system it's just not built for
that it's not Hadoop it's not related to
Hadoop it's not on top of Hadoop or
behind Hadoop it's it's it's an
alternative right and it's not it's not
a highly transactional system that's
designed for millions of transactions
per second right it's an analytic system
that's designed for bulk loads and
updates so but bulk loads and then lots
of analytics right one of the things
that Stonebraker says is we tried for 30
years to build databases that do
everything and we failed and therefore
one size does not fit all in a database
world and there's never going to be a
single database that does everything
well so let there be as many
purpose-built engines as possible so
with that I like to hand it over to
Chris and he will talk about the python
which is probably what you're here for
so thank you very much Thanks okay so
just some history about going to be pi
this was a project started by Jake van
der plas about a year ago and I come
from astrophysics my day job is
astronomy turned astronomy software
builder I guess at Harvard and recently
I've become involved in inside he be pi
and so I am now kind of maintaining this
library and pushing it forward so you
know about half of what I'm talking is
also just going to be bragging about
cool things that Jake Tazewell so I want
to give him credit for that so the
reason that I think's ITB pi is
interesting to me is that you know this
this array data model
that out who's talking about has a lot
of overlap with with numpy in with
pandas data frames and because that's
true we can kind of do interesting
things with interfaces and api's you
know so there's there's basically two
entry points to society beep I there's a
more traditional kind of direct
interface to query so you can send
queries to the database and upload and
download data but because there's so
much overlap conceptually with numpy
there's also a numpy like data container
and so a lot of you know the just kind
of like munging of sight eb arrays looks
almost identical to nut pie arrays and
so it allows you to kind of almost guess
how the library should behave without
thinking too much about the fact that
behind the scenes this is kind of
executing data queries and so it's kind
of a more maybe like sophisticated like
ORM if you will and so so here's just
kind of an example of working with that
numpy data container layer you connect
decide to be with this connect function
by default that will connect to a
database running on your machine but you
can give it a URL if you want to connect
to something that's on a different
machine all the communication happens
over HTTP and that connection object
that gets returned has a lot of methods
for creating a raise that look like
numpy methods so if you wanted to make a
three-row by four column random matrix
you can do this disclaimer you should
never make three world by four column
matrices than a database you know like
this is the sweet spot is for things
that are gigantic but you know this will
work it'll just be in a little slow and
so once you create a side of the array
it has a lot of properties that you're
used to it has a shape that's telling
you how many rows and columns and planes
and you know n-dimensional indices into
the array it has a d-type in this case
it created a 64-bit floated by default
it also has some side eb specific ideas
behind it so if you actually print it
out you you get this represents a this
is a side to be array and it has all
this extra information in it what does
that mean well it has a scheme and this
is describing kind of the side eb layout
the square bracket part talks about the
shape of the array and so there's two
dimensions called eyes ero and i won
they won from 0 to 2 and 0 to 3 and the
other numbers are describing those
things like the chunk size and overlap
which is basically hints decide to be
about how to chart it on different you
know hard drives if you have a cluster
side of the instance and then the angle
bracket part is the attributes stored in
each kind of cell location in the array
so in this case you have a single record
that's a double and it's called f0 it
also has a name and this is the name
that now exists inside the database so
if you were to connect to the database
in some other direction you could
directly interact interact with that
array through that name and then one of
the most important things is that you
know any point you can basically
materialize a side of the array into a
normal numpy array so the result of two
array is a normal numpy array that you
know basically goes the database
downloads the data and wraps it up into
something for you and you can go the
other direction too so you can wrap you
know numpy arrays and upload the
database you can download things into
data frames or just sparse arrays
sparsity is actually so Oh question
there's a it depends on what the data
type in the matrix is and so excit has
kind of a binary format and so in all my
cases if it's just kind of like in this
case it would be just streaming bytes
basically like the floating point
representation in a stream other things
like strings might actually transmit a
CSV for example in sparse arrays do
something a little bit different too so
sparsity is really built in decide to be
it's it's you know it's very common to
see very sparse arrays here's an example
of something that apparently has six
point four trillion elements but it only
has 15 million non no elements and it's
just worth noting that this is okay
inside the B and if you do math on I'm
big arrays like this it usually handles
that sparsity pretty intelligently
because it's kind of part of the design
of that the library all the math and all
the kind of like manipulation of a site
eb array behaves like you think with the
important caveat that it's happening in
a database instead of on your cpu so for
example if i want to aggregate this
array by summing over all the columns i
just call some of access equals one and
then the two array will get it into the
array and that is the same if i called
numpy that sum over the columns the
difference is you know this context
manager just turns on some debugging
information inside the context block to
show what messages actually get
exchanged with the database and so you
can he see if I run that same kind of
command again what's actually happening
is there's this aggregation command
that's getting sent a stye TV this is
now sigh tb's query language and i'll
come back to you know the details of
this language in a minute but the main
point
is that you know a lot of the normal
numpy methods are basically you know
wrappers around particular site ed
queries and so we're kind of translating
numpy idioms deciding the items for you
so you have to think about it as much
likewise you funks or you know like
element wise scalar functions a lot of
those are supported as well so you can
take logs you can do trigonometry on
these arrays those all map into database
calls you can do arithmetic so you can
either do scalar or rain arithmetic or
array array arithmetic broadcasting of
array arithmetic works like numpy so you
can you know take a square matrix and
had a column vector and that will you
know repeat the column vector will
repeat across and you can see this maps
into a slightly different query here um
so yeah so that's you know the the numpy
like data container the second way of
kind of getting at site eb is to go at a
slightly lower level and compose those
basically AFL calls directly so the
array functional language is site eb's
analog to sequel it's a lot different
from sequel um so it's it's functional
instead of declarative and it's it's a
right orient it's there's a set of a
hundred or so functions that will
manipulate a raise in various ways and
so you saw a bunch of examples of those
in the debugging information and from
side EP PI if you want you have access
to all of these and it's you know
there's trade-offs from working with
that lower level I mean first of all
it's a new API that you have to learn
and it's definitely lower level than
some of the numpy idioms but it does
offer you a lot finer grained control
and for the things that aren't yet
implemented in nice kind of Python
idioms inside of a pie you can develop
your own kind of utilities that will
kind of compose these things together
and you know I'm really growing enamored
of the kind of functional paradigm in
general there's talk tomorrow in
functional programming but for some
reason it seems to really kind of speak
to I think data pipeline processing
pretty nicely the fact that you're kind
of calling functions inside functions
just mentally maps well to my mind when
I think about doing a series of
operations on and some sort of big data
set and there's some nice ways in which
the AFL calls are nicely composable i'll
kind of point that out as we go through
so here's just an example I'm here's an
alias to the AFL binding and if I wanted
to know how many off-diagonal LM
greater than point five in an array
that's a combination of two things it's
a filter call and this string here
represents the actual criteria so that
the attribute is greater than point five
and the two dimensions are not equal to
each other so you see there's actually a
little mini kind of maybe template
library inside side to be for referring
to attributes and dimensions that gets
applied to every element and then after
you filter the array then you would a
grenade it with counting to kind of
count up how many elements are in there
one of the important things about AFL is
that it's all lazily evaluated which is
really nice because when you're working
with really big arrays you definitely
don't want to do what numpy does by
default which is basically every time it
sees kind of an operation like x plus 3
it immediately compute something and
allocates a new array and stores the
result in there and then you immediately
say you know x 5 and it does it again
and then at the end you say oh and I
only care about the first element and
then it all this wasted computation
because everything is lazily evaluated
nothing actually gets sent to the
database until you call a valor to array
and that's the point when the entire
kind of description of the computation
you want to perform gets sent over and
so so that's nice because you can
incrementally build up complex queries
you can write utility functions that
will do parts of kind of query
composition for you and you can do a lot
of munching those things before you do
any kind of computation and it also
gives the database itself the database
engine the opportunity to look at the
full query that you want to do and
potentially optimize it so for example
you would hope as you know in a lot of
situations cited be as smart enough that
if you do something and then the last
thing you do is like a sub grade
commander of filter command says I only
care about the first three elements it
knows it can you know in a lot of cases
ignore all the rest of the processing
that's in there you don't have to
necessarily manually order all of your
calls i mean we can have some
intelligence built into it to help you
with that okay so the other nice thing
about the AFL stuff is that all of the
dock strings for these AFL functions are
pulled from the site ed source code
itself which actually has pretty good
documentation for all these things and
because I python has such nice you know
introspection routines and the ability
to kind of like pop up docstrings in
these tooltip windows this is actually a
really nice way of just composing side
of you queries I would argue that side
of you pie is the best interface
currently for composing raw queries to
site eb and so that's kind of a nice
feature to have the last thing that you
can do
also students in manual query strings to
side of you as well and so if you want
to be fully kind of manual you have that
option here's an example of them so one
of the really nice operators in the
enterprise edition of sight EB is this
truncated singular value decomposition
SVD is kind of this workhorse linear
algebra routine study be has a really
fast one it is not yet to have any
direct binding and Python that will
change soon but at the moment you could
write a little function that does this
the important point is that you see we
just build an actual kind of query
string and then we call a query method
that actually just sends that thing over
that's a fully manual way of kind of
interacting with side eb this is just an
example of using that so you kind of
take a right wrap array is the command
that will then kind of grab an array
that already exists in the database
instead of creating a new one or
uploading something from Python so
here's an Iranian its transpose the
shape of this array it's reminiscent of
the netflix challenge this is supposed
to kind of mimic you know 500,000 movies
in eighteen thousand users and then the
values of this array are the ratings
that every user kind of gave to every
movie so it's a really sparse away with
about a hundred million nonzero elements
and you can compute the singular vectors
of that pretty quickly and it's worth
noting that the scales a lot the what
I'm told that the use case for this was
site ebru paradigm for had a client that
had a gigantic array of like 50 million
rows in 50 million columns with like
four billion nonzero elements and needed
to commute as media and then there was
there was no other solution they could
find that would actually even just
compute that let alone computer quickly
and and this algorithm actually could do
it and I think maybe a couple minutes on
a relatively modest cluster of computers
running inside e-beam that's kind of
cool okay so I want to just show a
couple of demos here here so so this is
an array this is a array of a subset of
the modis data modus is this project of
satellites that basically observe the
earth and measure things like elevation
and cloud cover and a bunch of
properties of the earth's surface and
atmosphere this is a subset of that
array that's looking at elevation and
here's the array itself there's one
interesting thing to note which is the
array has societies support the idea of
having origin
that are not at zero so in numpy your
arrays always are indexed by zero
incited me has the option of storing
things that are not at zero and so in
this case the dimensions of the array
are actually a discretized version of
latitude and longitude and so basically
all the latitude longitude data points
here were x 10000 they were converted to
integers and those became the array
indices here and so and so here's kind
of like a small subset of the array I'm
just plotting latitude longitude and
color coding by elevation here I'm just
to give you a sense of what the data
looks like it's a regularly gridded it's
pretty sparse and one thing you might
want to do is basically rege rid this
down and look at kind of zones of points
and average the elevation side that
point to make now kind of a smooth map
of a validation here from the nats
emotive satellite and so the set what
the satellite generates is a sparse mesh
that looks like that so it's very
precise about which samples it collects
but it doesn't collect the contiguous
map so thanks for that clarification
okay and so here's a little function
that uses sigh DB to basically create
that smooth grid it should be noted that
most of the math here is actually not
cited be specific all of this block is
basically the math you need to go from a
floating point latitude and longitude to
an array index so basically that you
know like x 10000 convert to an integer
but once you've done that and you want
to extract something around a latitude
and longitude with a given basically
field of view this sdb slice is just
like a numpy slice but it respects the
fact that side of the origins can be non
zero and so this could be a negative
number here for example and so this
extracts basically a sub array this
regrade command basically down samples
by a factor of 50 or so to kind of count
up all these all these are average all
these points inside that region and then
I call to array to download the array
and i called matlab to visualize it and
so then i get something that looks like
this and so i'm just now stepping back
and seeing a lot more detail about what
this is what this is doing and all of
the computation here is performed on
site eb this is a you know a subset of
the data but it could have been the
entire modis data set and you know sigh
TB is pretty quick about zoning into the
region you care about and making maps
like this on the fly so so I said that
Nathan was cute I am an astrophysicist
is so my main objection is I think all
of the
the motor satellites are pointed
backwards they should be looking out
instead of in and so let's see how do I
get back to oh this is right keynote and
my iPad the notebook look the same and
so I you know I have an idea about a way
this is really similar to astrophysics
and so here's a brief digression um you
know your kids might have asked you lies
in sky blue and maybe you know maybe you
don't it turns out to be the same reason
why sunsets are red and it's whenever
light passes through matter some of it
gets scattered and absorbed and in most
circumstances blue light is affected
more than red which means that during
the daytime a lot of the blue light from
the Sun scatters away and lights up the
skies if you look at some random
location you're seeing some of the blue
light from the Sun that's bouncing off
of air molecules and at sunset when the
Sun is skimming through lots of
atmosphere basically all of its blue
light is scattered away so if you look
directly at the Sun or near the Sun
there's no blue light left because it's
all went to basically lighting up the
rest of this guy during daytime and so
you see a red Sun so it's kind of
interesting because in this case the
color of the Sun is a proxy for how much
atmosphere sunlight is passed through
and this happens for other stars as well
this is now an Astrophysical image and
you see a bunch of stars and there's
this red looking data thing in the
middle and that red looking potato is a
cloud of gas that sits between us and
these stars and the stars are red
because they're you know they're star
light is passed through that and so we
can use the colors of these stars as a
proxy for how much mass is in this cloud
it's actually one of the best ways we
have of measuring the masses of
something to space if you ever thought
about how we get masses of things we
can't go to this is one of the ways we
do it and so here's math or if you want
to actually turn colors to two masses I
won't go to the details if you're a
statistic snared this turns out to be
the best linear unbiased estimator of
mass given things like the colors of
stars which are these numbers their
uncertainties which are the top numbers
what we know about optics and what we
know about kind of the intrinsic scatter
of star colors in the sky the main point
is that for every star we have
observations of things in red we formed
this little two by two matrix we invert
it we do a bunch of arithmetic and out
comes this AV value which is basically a
measure of mass between us and that star
so let me go back to the notebook
okay so this is that sense so here's the
matrix that elected before this is
basically implementing all of that
arithmetic inside of the operators it's
a little obnoxious right now because you
have to do a lot of string stuff that
will change shortly I'll come back to
that but basically and I'm just writing
very similar to code as to what I was
doing if I were to do this all in numpy
and this little function takes his input
array and expresses all of the
computation necessary to derive the mass
for a single star and so the cool thing
is that I can basically take this thing
because everything's lazily evaluated
and really nicely composable I can
basically take the same routine that I
had for the motifs data and then shove
in that basically mass calculation right
here and then instead of averaging to
get you know elevation which was stored
natively in the database I can aggregate
something that is derived from other
columns inside the database and so
here's an example of a famous star
forming region called row oh and this is
basically the distribution of maps on
this thing based by measuring colors of
millions of stars in the background and
to kind of steal a phrase from from Rob
and from Victor you know like once we
have a function that does something in
Python we're like one step away of
having a cool dashboard that lets us
kind of explore the parameters of our
algorithm and so here's something that
looks at a couple different reasons that
is just kind of centering and different
locations in the sky and I can also do
things like very so I should know this
is this is pre computed too so I'm not
doing this on the fly but I can i can
change basically my regrading parameter
like the bin size and i can see like as
I go up to find her bidding I get more
detail on the edges of these things but
I also see like holes start to open up
inside the cloud that turns out to be
like Astro physically real when you have
a lot of mass it starts to just absorb
and block background stars and so if you
make your bins too small you run out of
stars and that's something that's kind
of good to know and you can kind of see
that pretty easily here and again all of
that computation happens in the database
we just download the result and then
look at it with matplotlib okay so
that's kind of the state of sight of you
were right now where were we trying to
go with this there's a couple things
that we want to make better so first we
have a bit of a dichotomy right now
about what's evaluated eagerly and
lazily and in the next release basically
everything
b lazily evaluated which means that even
in this numb by container you can do
things like arithmetic or sums or
whatever and nothing will ever get sent
to the database until you say you know
like actually evaluate this and that
will let us work a little bit more
efficiently and not have so much kind of
intermediate computation and allocation
of arrays one of the things that you
know like really bothered me about about
the nice for example is that you have to
do all this like a string program I love
like this is I yeah I love programming
and strings and so there's a lot of nice
libraries that do really efficient
things but you have to pack code into
strings and when you do that you don't
have syntax checking usually don't have
like documentation introspection as
easily and so I'm sorry yeah so so
there's no reason and what I'd like to
build is basically something that does
this that you can kind of symbolically
manipulate the columns or the attributes
and the data and this again will just be
syntactic sugar around building up these
query string since that'll I think make
for a much nicer API in language for
working with today being pie and then
finally you know there's a whole bunch
of things that that map onto Python
idioms that aren't yet wrapped up into
nice things in citedby pie so for
example there's this nice numpy like
data container but there's a lot we
could do with pandas type thing so like
group buys for example map pretty
naturally on tues ITB kind of queries
and so there's no reason why we couldn't
have the ability to specify kind of
pandas like group buys and have that
work likewise there's a lot of linear
algebra and regression stuff that's
built in decide to be that maps pretty
nicely on two functions in scikit-learn
and so we'll be adding functions that
look like this you know the function
since I could learn and even things that
are like you know legitimate subclasses
of from from models and so I could learn
so if you want to do think like
cross-validation you can kind of plug
that into psych it learns really nice
modular API have the actual estimation
of a model happen inside your be but
things like cross-validation are kind of
composing things into pipelines happen
with second learn as well and then
finally you know like there's this
interesting idea of trying to integrate
this with other projects one notable
example is blaze you know blazes the
continuum project that attempts to be
kind of the next generation of numpy I
think one of the things that we really
need in the Python community is a
generalization of a numpy for things
that exist out of core in
and blaze is one of the promising
projects to do that and so you can
imagine a future where you have a blaze
front end that's backed by a site eb
database and then that would kind of
really achieve this goal of being fully
transparent that it would behave just
like any other blaze array but in the
back you would get a lot of the benefits
of the parallelism and hopefully
transactional consistency of sight of me
because it's backed by that data store
so i'm going to hand it over to Alex for
one last demo and it took so much this
is the SVG them do you want to do that
oh the SVD demos so I you know so that's
the the netflix I'm over here I kind of
showed the results here well actually
like you do the Regina wits thing we can
come back to it of Lascaux case that's
cool do you want to just set it started
running yep all right so so this this is
the what I was talking about earlier is
the kind of correlation computation for
stock trades this is the same similar
kind of correlation computation for
genomics and we were asked to do this by
some of some of the folks who are
working with so this is a very much more
of a real workflow so this data comes
from a project again by the government
called the TCGA it stands for the Cancer
Genome Atlas basically it collects
tissue samples from cancer patients and
does all sorts of genomic analysis on
the tissue and we're working with a lot
of bioinformatics and genomics companies
to the point where we figured out a good
way to represent this data insights ITB
and a lot of this data is just very
naturally fits into the array form um so
what's running here is this is running
yeah okay so it's it's it's taken a
while maybe for the network so what what
we have here is it is gene expression
data how many folks are familiar with
bioinformatics okay so quite a few so
this is alumina RNA seek expression data
the array is three-dimensional it has it
has a it has a
value which is the the the alumina RNA
seek expression value for a particular
tumor for a particular sample and for a
particular probe so for this particular
gene expression platform there are
probes that measure the expression of
individual genes based on RNA and again
as I said earlier we people want to know
this because they want to know if a
particular gene is upregulated in a
cancer tissue sample usually it's an
indication that that gene causes cancer
and moreover just because you have lung
cancer doesn't mean it's always
triggered by the same mutation right so
for a particular tumor there are often
multiple genes that could be to blame
for it and so it's very important to
analyze how different genes interact and
so an expression an expression means how
how much of the gene has sort of turned
on in the cell and if the expression
value is high that would mean that you
know the gene is upregulated and that
might cause the cell to divide rapidly
and so what we do first is we just
filter out all of the samples and all of
the probe values for particular cancer
so we take from the three-dimensional
data set we select the slice which just
corresponds to here we have eight
hundred and seventy eight samples and
20,000 genes the 20,000 genes is roughly
how many genes there are in in the human
genome 878 samples with this particular
cancerous happens to be breast cancer
then this this code essentially centers
this this code center is the matrix so
that you know we have many samples not
all samples have RNA expression data for
them of course there's a lot of sparsity
and data management that has to happen
so the first thing that happens is a
matrix get centered and densified right
so we compute the dense matrix using
just the samples that we have the data
for so 878 real samples then I'm going
to enter the matrix by subtracting the
mean of each column so this this is a
group that aggregate it gets subtracted
from the from the matrix itself and then
we take the dot product which is
multiply the matrix by its trans
and this whole thing ran in 54 seconds
in the database yeah it's a fairly small
matrix but point out we have the entire
TCGA loaded on the system so the benefit
we get here is just being able from the
hole from the whole data set select the
particular platform a particular cancer
do a very quick matrix that
identification and go from the data
select to analysis fairly quickly and
now now that we have the output of this
as a correlation matrix as I shown you
so it's the 20,000 by 20,000 genes and
we can use this filter command to get
the genes that are highly correlated
just to show a graph so in reality which
you would add to this workflow with some
kind of a regular regularization step
you might not look at highly correlated
genes or you might look at other factors
you might look at jeans that interest
you but if we just look at the highly
correlated genes we download the data
into Python and we'll make a plot like
this so these are the genes in this
cancer that had very high correlation
against each other and this would be a
thresholded correlation plot right so
this is this is something that got
genomics folks very interested very
interested in you know we can do that we
did this with our expressions a lot of
the genomics platforms look very similar
to this and and and you know a lot of
people are interested in things like
comparing their own data versus public
TCGA data and if they see a particular
phenomenon than their data set how does
it compare to TCGA and so we're doing a
lot of work with bio with bioinformatics
companies and that font and as I pointed
out this kind of correlation analysis
you know happens in a lot of places
finance being one of them so hopefully
this gives you an idea of sight ebn sigh
DB pie and how the two can be used
together and I think looks like we have
11 or 15 minutes for questions
sir yeah so side ed seems really cool if
you already have data that can be loaded
into ciety be huge no mixed data or or
these images but i'm wondering if you if
your data set isn't already cleaned
right and can already be automatically
loaded by side DB especially if it's big
data what's the recommended way to go
ahead and clean and load that well one
of the reason I like to show the TCGA
example is because it's not it's not
that clean i mean we actually well TCGA
is shipped in many many small files and
we wrote some scripts to load all of
those files together in society be so
sigh TB will take CSV input right CSV or
tsv input and it gets loaded in as a
one-dimensional array once it gets
loaded in you can do some pre-processing
on the one-dimensional array to pick out
values that are questionable filter
things out do some you know cardinality
estimates things like that just to sort
of you know clean the data up and then
after you've done some of that you could
say okay you know these are my
dimensions go create my
multi-dimensional arrays that I can then
quickly analyze right so there are some
facilities built in for that and and
more of that is definitely on the way
yeah so well we actually have a fast CSV
loader right so we have a and it's
actually written in Python right it's
called load CSV by it's in the free
version it takes the input CSV file it
splits it into into pieces actually not
yet chunks the CSV is then shipped to
all the instances and then all the
instances load the CSV data in parallel
so the parsing of the CSV is also
distributed so the guys at lbnl like
this there they were getting like two
gigabytes per second load times for
their CSV files
so they got they gave us good feedback
on that we're also working on loading
other formats natively directly adding
more kinds of loaders that might happen
like somebody at NCBI wrote their own
VCF loader that's on github so if you
have VCF data which is a particular
genomics format you could you could use
that so when you were you know you are
describing that where you're describing
the array a multi-dimensional array and
you talked about several dimensions and
then attributes at each point sell the
lightbulb went off that looks an awful
lot like the star schema in the sort of
database where hot day where else I've
been working with as that connection
ever come up in your work well i'm not
i'm not sure i would think of the star
schema as many as a single central table
entity right with many indices does that
it joins too yeah there's there's some
similarity but and in some ways so there
are parallels but the differentiation of
psyche be is essentially you take your
relational table right which is just a
bunch of columns you could think of it
as a one-dimensional array or so on and
what you get worse idb is you say column
one column three and column 5 are
dimensions and they're special and
you're to treat them specially and once
I DB reorganizes data in that way then
you get very good selection based on
dimensions very fast lighting and if you
happen to have a two dimensional thing
you could get very good linear algebra
results right so we're four but we are
forcing the user to say these things are
dimensions and and by forcing the user
to make that choice to get very very
interesting way of looking at their data
a very good way of organizing it in a
very very high performance when it comes
to certain computations that okay well
it seems like data warehouse with a star
schema you have to do the same thing you
have to pick out your dimensions anyway
so I'm interested to play with it
another question I had this is probably
an easy one if you've got several ways
you can join across some of the things
like this yeah okay
yeah the most natural ways to do a joint
on dimensions okay right as you said but
but ah there's other ways to do joins as
well and there's actually Oh more
complex types of join that site eb
supports for example there's this
there's a way to do to take too sparse
arrays and perform a join where the non
where cells that don't overlap and
sparsity would would appear so sort of
more like a union type of computation
right so by reasoning in data and then
there's there's also a way to get say
joy in a two-dimensional array with
another two dimensional array on one
dimension and then you would get three
dimensions back right so they think
things like that are possible yeah are
you familiar with by tables and how
would you compare these sadly be invited
all high tables is a hdf5 wrapper and so
there's a lot of overlap in that they're
both storing tabular data and they're
trying to do it out of core I would I'm
speculating a little bit about PI tables
but my guess is that side eb is a little
bit better situated for things like
distributed processing for parallelism
and for transactional security so if you
have kind of multiple axis at the same
time I'm not sure that high tables is
really set up to give you any kind of
database type guarantees there okay I
was curious what happens if you call an
umpire function on a SAT ebra yeah so I
most likely it breaks I so there is this
interesting thing that you could think
about doing which is make this I DB
array like a legit subclass of numpy
array and there's there's ways of
basically kind of transparently
accessing the by taxes and you could try
to do something like that and as not so
plus I'm sorry it doesn't need to be a
subclass all right right with something
that's something that would kind of
transparently which you realize into an
umpire ray um I the reason we haven't
done that so far is that a lot of times
it's a really bad idea to materialize
the data into an array and so my concern
is that if you do that you pass it to
some function that you know somewhere
deep in the pipeline it says all I need
the whole array and then it's
ridiculously slow and it's really hard
to
so right now we have a narrower
interface that's more I think better
tuned to doing things the way the
database wants it to be done I guess but
it's it's worth thinking about more my
nails yeah thank you I remember we have
these cards here so do you want to use
site eb grab let's grab a card with
instructions thank you very much yep
ladies and gentlemen thanks for
attending the talk there is a